une heure entière de jeux gratuits c'est
la formule proposée par le golf de
guerville dans le cadre d'initiation de
quoi apprendre les bases ont fait le
mouvement de balancier en essayant de se
relâcher
ça va demander une certaine coordination
et un relâchement du corps pour arriver
à rendre le corps disponible à l'essai
le mouvement vraiment naturel se faire
c'est pas difficile fin arrive
effectivement comme ils le disent à se
relâcher parce qu'on est complètement
figé sur le club
un court placée sous le signe de la
bonne humeur qui donne envie à certains
d'aller plus loin
c'est toujours des parcours aussi très
jolie donc c'est pour ça je veux mettre
au golf je trouve ça sympa je pense que
partie bois adhérer et à croquer le but
c'est de rendre le golf accessible à
tous et à toutes
que ce soit plus fun et tout en en
gardant un esprit soit familiale soit
amical une opportunité pour le golf de
guerville qui vient de rouvrir ses 18
trous après deux ans de travaux de
rénovation en a pas l'exploitation de
quatre trous du coup qu'on a reconstruit
si les travaux ont duré à peu près un an
il ya eu un temps de réflexion pour ça
où et comment les construire sur le sur
le terrain à les trous sont ouverts
depuis lundi dernier on a ouvert le 21 à
tout le public
l'architecte a voulu conserver l'esprit
qui avait auparavant c'est à dire d'être
ou plutôt étroit au début est large à
l'arrivée
objectif du golf de guerville et gagner
une centaine d'abonnés d'ici un an dont
une trentaine ayant débuté par
l'initiation gratuite